friends and students are describing to
us the suspect as a troubled violent
teenager before he was kicked out of
Stoneman Douglas high one student who
knew Nick Cruz says he had threatened
other students and overnight the FBI
began searching the home here in
parkland where Cruz lived
that's where Jericka Duncan is this
morning Jericka good morning to you good
morning the home where Nicholas Cruz
most recently stayed is behind me here
and around the corner you can see
there's still a heavy police presence on
the ground and also a helicopter in the
air now according to the attorney for
the family where Nicholas Cruz was
staying he was staying with that family
for the last three months or so and he
had been bouncing around from home to
home after his mother died in November
we'll now some friends and students who
knew Cruz are speaking out painting a
very complicated disturbing picture of a
troubled young man as investigators
search through the home where Nicholas
Cruz lives
new details are emerging about the 19
year olds unsettled past they let him
live here because he didn't have some
place to live
attorney Jim Lewis represents the family
who gave Cruz a place to stay they can't
believe that someone who lived in their
home that was so close to them for this
relatively short period of time was
capable of such a horrible horrible act
Lewis says Cruz was getting an adult
education and working at a dollar store
where he was a cashier he told the Sun
Sentinel newspaper Cruz legally
purchased the ar-15 weapon used in the
attack
it's like someone would do this you
would expect it to be this this kid
after the shooting students described
Cruz as a loner who struggled in school
a lot of people were saying that it was
gonna be him stuff like that we actually
threw our kids through drug time like
that saying that here's me this the one
who screwed up the school but it turns
out you know everyone predicted it Paul
Gould lived next door to Cruz in
parkland and says the death of his
adoptive mother had a major impact at
times he had so much anger and pain
inside of him Gould says Cruz complained
about being picked on and bullied in
school kids mistreated him and obviously
he wasn't given the best you know hand
in life you see that picture what is it
how does it make you feel this makes me
sick it makes me sick to think that he
would do something like time gold says
Cruz's adoptive mother did have him in
counseling but that all ended according
to gold when his mother passed away
Cruz is currently in custody at the
Broward County Sheriff's Office
tareka Duncan thank you very much